avete presente tipo quelle foto quindi
tanto girano su internet quando andate a
vedere i film in streaming su vari temi
training è stata data una lametta che è
praticamente appaiono delle immagini c'è
scritto sopra questa immagine è vero è
falsa e da un secolo che ormai gira un
giochino che è diventato un sacco
popolare susta cagata qua che si chiama
rial orfei e socio quarti mente una foto
davanti e tu devi di conoscere se sta
foto è reale o è finta siccome non l'ho
mai fatto facciamo start
voglio vedere che cos'è che secondo me
questa roba è eri al giusto c'è crudo e
la mamma degli haters credo che sia
ritagliata questa ma non ne sono sicuro
non so come real era fake cazzo ciao
ragione vedi porca e ho anche detto
[ __ ] però sembrano questa rial a
questa varia questa è assolutamente fake
un orso non può avere un culo del genere
fake anno era il pesce a va bene penso
fosse il culo dell'orso questa invece e
buffet che penso mi chiedo non si poteva
non può rischiare una roba del genere un
aereo è infatti sembra non troppo vere
ragazzi west aerei al quale non era
difficile tra vj fa un video sulla vis
nova queste fake sai perché in tipo sei
foto in una si parlava di bacche e
nell'altra si parla di uccelli
[ __ ] come rari al haniq al
piccione non c'è io pensavo a quella
cosa dietro pensate
non credo che un cane possa essere così
veramente poi esiste un cane così riad
afferma che questa sopra real non vedo
niente di fake questa ri all
ho mica 8 su 12 raga che schifo questa è
la cosa da photoshop ragazzi non si
capisce mica impossibile real ma cosa
aveva fatto da est in fotoritocchi di
merda riad orfei faith [ __ ] che
neanche mezzo o la metà nel azzeccata e
non è possibile caccia lac non lo sapevo
che lei prova a fare un'altra roba
dieci secondi 15 per rispondermi un
penny che cade da un grattacielo può
essere veloce sufficientemente non c'era
una persona vero sempre con stato
convinto che fosse vero non è vero
se quindi se buttate gli euro dal
balcone non ammazzato nessuno quindi io
sono sotto buttateli più dell'acqua il
caffè il drink più popolare del mondo si
ok però forse la coca cola in realtà va
bene harry potter e l'arci nemico di tom
mar valori davvero il prefisso di mega
rappresenta un milione si cazzo che culo
la sindrome jing della cina e quando gli
ostaggi creano empatia con i loro
rapitori la sindrome la cina falso
la sindrome di stoccolma non sapevo ho
visto come ammazzare il capo e vivere
felici l'altro giorno è il fondatore del
breuil perché ha inventato il coso per i
ciechi per leggere per i ciechi era
cieco no non è vero era cieco bene porca
[ __ ] vedevo l'ora di scoprirlo non
vedevo l'ora perché c'è quindi non
vedevo l'ora next question 3 su 10 sono
fortissimo a questi giochi cazzo play
again troll falls le tapas sono le più
comuni scandinavi alla pet heiser le
tapas nuvole sono messicane falls la
base il basketball è lo sport con
maggiore origini americane
perché anche in giappone lo giocano un
sacco meno male al basket ball non il
baseball chi pensava al baseball che
[ __ ] la pelle il più grande organo
del corpo umano vero che se la sapevo
madonna minchia alle elezioni scienze
porca eva l'anno in cui la volta che mi
aveva dato 3 st [ __ ]
ho finito 8 studiata da tre su dieci ho
preso 8 questo la dice lunga sui miei
voti scolastici ragazzi va beh la più
grande delle definizione di idioma sì ma
cazzo se passate la grammatica inglese
poi idioma frase è l'iperbole sinonimo
di pergole madonna min che i colloqui di
lavoro mi fanno una pippa
porca eva in inglese o ma neanche nella
top di vb del liceo linguistico la più
la definizione migliori di morbido
bruson
dopo questa qua va a cagare nella
tazzina della regina elisabetta cioè non
ho parole
la miglior definizione di e viscere it o
gatto o finisci o gatto finish cat gatto
non so che cazzo
espose in brains miglior definizione di
ed echi ology origin l'ultima ragazza 10
su 10 definizioni di monetario finanzia
le finanze sia con finanzia questo bene
giusto
sì io resto ho fatto meglio in questo
che era su il lag sulla grammatica
inglese che quello di prima che erano
qui che potrà capire chiunque possa fare
ragazzi l'ultimo qui si può vedere che
cosa esce fuori ma me la sono cavata
niente male direi da aqua lui trovare un
nome alla cosa l'oggetto figo non lo sa
in italia non sapere in inglese su serve
sta roba trawel la sapevo e non ho mica
tirato a caso sapevo perfettamente ma
sappi voi sabi minchia questa la
sapevano una madre che mangia sushi una
volta un giorno su due bikers ecco sarà
semplice bmx bike ok a un nome quella
merda shaft lingua si chiama lingua alla
roba del nostro
e vabbè minchia cos'è schumer schumacher
joong punto dove colpire i giganti to
killing dem affanculo nape non lo so zio
non lo so me la mettono nel budino sta
roba non lo so io come si chiamano anche
in italiano rankin lo sapevo invece lo
facevo solo scena you are in the top mai
ti fai perse mi che al 95 per cento non
è riuscito neanche a fare quattro su
dieci risotto is a como in italia ris
drives di risotto the world from italia
riso il mini il rais grazie a dei
ragazzi lasciamo perdere che è meglio
che mi chiama veramente schifo come
punteggio ma ok però io vi sia piaciuto
spero fatto pagare un po in tutto tranne
nuovamente fatto cagare in tutto spero
siate più bravi di me nei quiz nei test
soprattutto però sono stato bravo quando
dovevo trovare i sinonimi in inglese era
il più difficile quello avevo fatto
meglio non so come per ragazzi spero che
mi sia piaciuto come senso bisogna
momento non mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e co e descrizioni di siete mi
civili diavolo prossimo video per
ragazzi